welcome back march madness at the
cosmopolitan is more than watching and
playing basketball in the decked out
belmont ballroom you can also celebrate
at their sports book rocky is there live
to show us what's on tap hi rocky
hey youtube yeah so you know you have a
ball in one hand for march madness but
in the other hand you got to have a
drink so we're here at the sports book
at the bar um fedora what is on the menu
for your epic march madness weekend
we've got a selection of you know
breakfast lunch and dinner with foods
all right because my time starts early
in the morning oh so it goes late at
night 7 in the morning till 9 30 oh my
god greatest election night stadium food
we've got crab crab uh maryland crab
cake sliders we've got philly steak and
cheese breakfast sandwiches
uh and hattie b's chicken tenders oh my
god everything in between so it's a it's
a great selection of food i think people
will be excited so good and while he's
making our drink let's talk about where
else you can celebrate march madness
other than the hoops and hops
um belmont ballroom oh we've got plenty
of facilities in the in the resort that
are showing it we've got the barbershop
which is going to be showing oh that's a
dope spot live music venue okay we've
got click bar and lounge which is also
showing it
and you can also see it in the sports
book that we're in right now right of
course you've got tv screens all over
the place here in the cosmopolitan so
let's talk about the drinks so you have
some sports themed drinks on the menu
here at the sports book so i think the
bartender right now at the sports book
he's making uh take the ball and run
take the ball and run the ball and drink
okay in basketball take the ball and run
would be called a what fedor traveling i
travel we don't want to do that right
but we do want to drink it so let's go
have it have a taste what's in this one
this one's got a patron
and a tamarind ginger and some sprite
soda squirt soda sorry oh man that's
refreshing that's really good i think
it's great for the seasoning i love it i
love it and you got a little salt on the
side all right tell everybody how they
can get tickets to come join you guys so
just go on ticket go you go to the
website cosmopolitanlasvegas.com
and go to the event section or you can
just go straight to ticketmaster easy as
that all right in vegas march madness a
ball in one hand a drink in the other
cheers to march madness guys we'll send
it back to you perfect yeah rocky and i
are having a